what's harder perception of control for
these problems so being able to
perfectly perceive everything or
figuring out a plan once you perceive
everything how to interact with all the
agents in the environment in your sense
from a learning perspective is
perception or action harder and then
giant beautiful multitask learning
neural network the hardest thing is
having accurate representation of the
physical objects in vector space so
transportation the visual input
primarily visual input some sonar and
radar and and then at creating the an
accurate vector space representation of
the objects around you once you have an
accurate vector space representation the
flanker and controller is relatively
easier that is relatively easy basically
once you have accurate vector space
representation then then you're kind of
like a video game like it cars in like
Grand Theft Auto or something like they
work pretty well they drive down the
road they don't crash you know pretty
much unless you crash into them that's
because they've they've got an accurate
vector space representation of where the
cars are and they're just that and then
they're rendering that as the as the
output
you